[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
horror film called x the man with the
x-ray eyes spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
dr james xavier is a physician and an
ambitious researcher he wishes to invent
something revolutionary in medicine that
will one day save many lives in the
opening scene he is getting his eyes
checked at a colleague dr sam's clinic
it has only been three months since the
last checkup which seems strange to sam
james answers that he is about to use an
experimental eye drop on himself so he
needs to get his eyes checked frequently
although james is a certified
professional with years of experience dr
sam thinks being a subject to your own
experiment is a bad idea a human eye can
only see up to 10 of the things that
actually exist in the world james is
working to create an eye drop so people
can see beyond what their eyes allow
them to with this new product they will
be able to see the ultraviolet and x-ray
wavelengths and beyond the idea is
absurd but the doctor is ambitious to
make it come true after the meeting
james goes to his lab and meets his
close friend and colleague dr diane she
informs him that the people who are
funding the lab are growing impatient
they have spent a lot of money on
james's experiment and are now
pressuring dr diane for results she is
particularly frustrated because james
hasn't told her anything about his study
james agrees to show her his discovery
and brings her to the lab after
explaining what the eye drop does he
uses it on a monkey to see if it really
worked the animal is made to take a
color assessment test even though he
cannot see the colored sheets from his
point of view he makes the correct guess
this proves that he can actually see
through the colored sheets and can tell
which one comes after another either
that or the monkey is just lucky dr
diane is left stunned at the animal's
intelligence but a few minutes later the
monkey dies of cardiac arrest the death
is sad but it doesn't take away from the
fact that the eye drop does exactly what
it was meant to do james wants to use
the eye drops for medical purposes
because that way doctors can tell what
is wrong with a patient just by looking
at them however he desperately needs the
investor's money for further research dr
diana arranges a meeting between him and
the investors a few days later the
doctor is so eager to prove his
invention's efficiency that he is ready
to use it on himself he tells dr sam
about his plan but sam is strictly
against it according to him the
experiment is not worth risking his life
still james somehow manages to convince
sam to help him in the application
process in the following scene dr sam
puts the drop into his eyes initially
james loses the perception of vision and
sees only colors and patterns he
describes it as seeing more light than
he has ever seen in his life then he
discovers he can see through the piles
of paper on the table and read them
without turning them over he is
overjoyed that the product works but he
still can only see through the surface
of objects the doctor gets too excited
and puts two more drops into his eyes he
regrets the decision instantly as the
second drop burns more than the first
one in the following scene dr diane and
sam are in a meeting with the investors
james was unable to come because he is
recovering from the eye injury the
investors no longer believe in his work
and decide to quit funding the project
dr diane and sam come to him to give him
the news james has bandages over his
eyes to help him with the pain but it is
almost as if they don't exist because he
can see very clearly through them a week
later he returns to the hospital the
nurse introduces him to a little girl
who has been diagnosed with stenosis but
with his new ability james finds out the
diagnosis is wrong and she actually has
a tumor attached to her heart thanks for
letting us know she's going to die
anyway james he tells the girl's primary
doctor about it but the man refuses to
listen driven by pride that evening dr
diane takes him to a party james doesn't
really enjoy such gatherings but he
tries to socialize and dance with a
beautiful girl suddenly his eyes itch
and when he opens them again he can see
through people's clothes james looks
around in shock and sees dr diane naked
upon hearing that she is exposed in his
view dr diane quickly brings him home
the following day is the day of the
little girl's surgery james repeatedly
requests the primary doctor to
reconsider his decision because the
diagnosis is incorrect when he still
doesn't listen james takes extreme
measures and cuts the doctor's hand
right before the operation starts due to
the injury he can no longer operate on
the girl and instead of going to jail
for some reason james takes over the
procedure he does the correct surgery to
remove the tumor and saves the little
girl's life with his own reputation the
other doctor accuses him of malpractice
even though the surgery was successful
the next day james goes to sam for a
routine eye checkup sam registers that
james can only see bones muscles and
nerves in people and is quickly losing
his ability to see things as they would
seem to normal human eyes it turns out
that he has been using the eye drops
continuously since the last use sam
urges him to stop immediately but james
is too concerned about his experiment to
care about his health with the
continuous use of the eye drops soon he
will be able to see what no man has ever
seen in the history of humans the reason
that jake paul exists
worried about his friend's health sam
forcefully tries to sedate him in the
ensuing struggle james accidentally
pushes him out the window and kills him
he feels terrible for what he did but
has no way to change the past dr diane
who witnessed everything doesn't want
james to be charged with accidental
death hence she helps him escape before
the cops arrive the very next day news
about the killer doctor spreads around
town james can no longer be seen in
public as his old self nor can he
continue practicing medicine he changes
his name and appearance and starts
working as a talent in a freak show he
uses his ability to guess the things
inside of viewers pockets and earns
money in return james had thought that
his discovery would save millions of
lives and is sad about what it has come
down to the guy who owns the freak show
named crane recognizes james's talent he
does his best to find out what his trick
is but is unsuccessful one day a lady is
injured near their set james quickly
scans her for injuries and sees that she
has a broken leg he helps her the best
he can before the paramedics arrive
seeing him handle the situation so well
crane registers that he might be a
doctor he offers james a deal that is
bound to make them a lot of money he
suggests they establish a diagnosis
clinic where people can come before they
go to the doctor to find out what
exactly is wrong with their bodies that
sounds illegal and stupid james likes
the idea but only because that way he
can use his power for good the next day
they return to the former city and stay
in a rustic apartment before going to
sleep james puts the eye drops in his
eyes again it has been a routine ever
since he first tested it with dr sam
with this drop he manages to see through
the ceiling above him james quickly puts
on black glasses so people won't get to
see what the drops have done to his eyes
right after crane brings their first
client an old wealthy lady who has been
having severe health troubles lately she
is worried it might be cancer but only a
look at her tells james that she is just
tired because of old age he asks her not
to worry because the pain will go away
if she takes a rest for a few days later
that day james sits alone in his room
and records the progress of the medicine
he is interrupted by crane who urges him
to come outside quickly james does is
told and finds a crowd of people waiting
for him to take a look at them and find
out their illnesses the old lady from
yesterday has spread the word about him
among the circle of her rich friends i
guess none of them could afford a real
doctor james sees the patients and tends
to their problems while crane pockets
several bills throughout the day their
clinic grows more famous with time one
day dr diane gets a hint about the
clinic and rushes to meet the new
miracle doctor knowing exactly who it is
she sits in front of james but he fails
to recognize her and can only see her
muscles when dr diane speaks the
memories of his former life flood back
to james she reveals that she had
several patients come in knowing exactly
what was wrong with them eventually she
put two and two together and found out
about his return for the first time in
months the doctor has someone to share
his feelings with he reveals that at
night he cannot sleep because he sees
through his own eyelids the drops have
turned into a curse that flipped his
life but he cannot stop using them at
this point dr diane is worried about his
health and about the police finding him
because of his popularity she urges him
to come somewhere safe but crane doesn't
agree he is too used to making money off
of james's talent and doesn't want to
stop the couple fights crane and runs
away from the town now james wants to
learn to control his eyes but needs
money for the experiment hence they go
to vegas and end up in a casino james's
ability is a blessing when he gets to
play poker by the end of the night he
has gathered enough money to help him
survive a month but then the casino's
manager and a policeman approach him
accusing him of cheating since no one
can win that many rounds in a single
night as james tries to explain himself
a policeman pulls his glasses away to
reveal that his eyes have changed color
the sight takes him by surprise for a
second but he soon recognizes james as
the crazy doctor who ran away after
murdering his friend backup is called to
arrest him but james gets in a car and
runs away before he is caught they
follow him in a chopper and while trying
to run away from it he crashes
fortunately for the doctor he survives
the crash and comes out of the car
unharmed after walking for a few minutes
he ends up at an open church where
people are busy singing religious songs
by now james's eyes have turned
completely black the father assures him
that god will save him but james knows
he is too far gone to be saved he looks
at the sky and can see god at this point
huh and here i thought seeing through
clothes was the real heaven two
policemen arrive with dr diane but do
not arrest him drowning in regret for
what he has done james gouges both of
his eyes the movie ends as he turns to
the camera and reveals that his eyes are
gone
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching